there's nothing that's been more
important or vital to me culturally
artistically than the color purple
it is a solid base of spiritual
and emotional power for me every woman
and man who has been invisible who has
felt unseen and unvalued
this is their story today I teach at
times about a place called Africa now
mommy's come from Queens over there you
know what that means
we royalty
the original film is one of the
cornerstones of culture certainly Black
Culture what if we put it back out into
the world and kind of paint our own
version of it we want to connect with
the younger generation Blitz is our
incredible director he's putting a
little modern twist to it but still
capturing the essence of what this film
means it's the story of finding yourself
and living it and going after it no
matter what it's about Sisterhood and
Redemption where you get to see all
these strong women shine and be who
they're truly meant to be
[Music]
now I come here out of respect
but if there ain't nothing to get that
show ain't none again
the human story and that's what makes it
ultimately great and enduring
it's fun and joyful as we say in our
community it fills you up so you leave
feeling full
[Music]
hi
I feel so blessed to join the color
purple family it's just an incredible
piece of art that's how filmmaking
should be Joy excitement Color Purple
let's go
[Music]